I'm doing a juice cleanse today I like
to do juice cleanses after I purposely
destroy my stomach decide to smoke lay
in bed and eat 15,000 calories yesterday
so I ordered a juice cleanse before I
went to sleep getting a bit miserable
ate a bowl of dry lettuce cuz I just
needed to chew something so bad oh boy I
have a lot to say about this one and
know a juice cleanse is not the solution
if anything this just further
perpetuates and amplifies the binge
restrict repent repeat cycle to
purposefully ruin your gut only to try
to then heal it by abstaining from any
food insinuates a real All or Nothing
Last Supper mentality around food where
you're either binging and smoking in bed
all night or you're making yourself
miserable drinking green juices and
chewing undressed lettuce because you
desperately just need to chew something
this is not a cute look I don't know why
anyone with influence would want to
share this journey cuz it's not the vibe
so friends please do not intentionally
overeat thinking you can just undo the
damage with the juice cleanse because
the more you restrict the greater
chances of a repeat episode next